the gyro can experience did you see that
[ __ ] where this guy had a super fast and
he's apparently a very famous designer
and he put his sneakers on the roof of
this dope [ __ ] Ferrari that he owns
he owns this crazy green Ferrari super
fast yes yes gorgeous and he put his
sneakers which are green as well on the
front and Ferrari sent him like a cease
and desist and they threatened him this
guy Philip please
lashes out a Ferrari / cease and desist
letter but like look at the photo when
an alligator Jeff delivers he owes me I
asked my wife and this guy's a fake look
how dope that colour is I'm not usually
in a green car that would that lizard
gunking amazing Porsche makes the gt3 in
it but that's so like a little metallic
yeah there's a hot electric green yeah
see there's any other pictures of his
car but look at that he's got these dope
sneakers and they're sitting on his
Ferrari and Ferrari was angry they were
like you're using our brand or something
like that oh because I'm trying to think
is he painted green then are those his
shoes and it's with the Ferrari so
they're like they said Ferraris
trademarks and model cars are are
associated in your pictures with a
lifestyle totally inconsistent with
Ferraris brand perception in connection
with performers making sexual innuendos
and using Ferrari cars as props in a
manner which is per se distasteful this
behavior tarnishes the reputation of
Ferraris brands and causes Ferrari
further material damage in fact the
undesirable connection between Ferraris
trademarks on the one hand and Philip
planes line of shoes and the
questionable manner in which they're
promoted on the other hand is
interfering negatively with the rights
enjoyed by Ferrari selected licenses
which are exclusively entitled to use
Ferraris trademarks to produce and
promote line of shoes Ferrari brass nuns
that's why I love FRA branded shoes [ __ ]
yeah they sell you know they sell more
merch than cars they make their money
off merch but guy is a very successful
designer his stuff is very expensive
where re no you get that [ __ ] out of
here
get that [ __ ] out you leave it fryer boy
horrible no I'm just kidding dude no
here's the thing he probably got
allocated the super fast cuz you can't
you know how Ferrari work she can't just
walk in the store and buy one so you got
allocated one so he probably owned other
v12s it's a crazy like he's doing
Ferraris for ten years he said there you
go so he gets allocated the new ones so
he probably had access to the TDF then
he got a super fast and then in painted
green like an [ __ ] with the cool
colored green now he can't well he might
have had it may paint to [ __ ] no I don't
know I don't think fry offers that green
he'd right no no way
really no he did that himself that's
like fries like Jesus Christ dude be
cool really yeah you don't think Ferrari
offers that color I don't think so
I would doubt it have you ever seen an
upright he if they did my man heap I
paid such a premium for that color
because they don't make that color well
the only one I've seen in the flesh is
yours I've never seen one of those cars
before yeah yeah well I seen one of them
at a dealership because I I saw there's
only 700 of them in the states I saw of
gray like that battleship gray god it
made my dick hard certain cars do man
like I want so many cars I know it's
crazy right yeah man it's a problem with
cars I'll tell you that I love I
absolutely love Ferrari I'm Afra I love
Ferrari there's nothing like a Porsche
mm I owe my fans of Drive intently it
bet you name I've had all the cars
there's nothing as far as the driving
experience but in the Porsche ya know I
think I have to always have a Porsche
the reason why I still have that 2007
gt3 RS that shark works worked on this
one every stars every time I get in
there I get happy it just feels amazing
it's just it won that and also can feel
and I want a goddamn manual transmitted
to the flusher is the last of the
mohicans they still don't do it though
for the gt3 RS and they still don't do
it for the gt2 RS which is they get in
the gg3 touring the gt3 and the gt3
touring they'll they'll sell you with a
manual trans which is what yeah I want
to get one of those do the new Corvette
a banned in the manual I know cuz
they're the fastest [ __ ] now that I
agree calm you
I mean you drive a Tesla but so what hmm
but the Corvette to me it
looks badass they completely ripped off
Ferrari I mean that's yes I mean come on
some mid-engine car mid-engine cars yeah
but I have a 65 Corvette with a giant
Hurst shifter with a [ __ ] cue ball
the cue ball shift that's the real guy
that's America I know side pipes [ __ ] I
know whoa
[Applause]